you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess calm
and I just challenged computer
impossible this is a 15-2 game let's
start out with d5 I like seeing c3 as a
start okay
Knight f3 I'm considering right now is
how to get my Bishop out to f5
successfully playing it right away Queen
b3 is an issue not a good way to defend
against b6 so I may want to copy for a
moment
what's c6 and now I'm in a position to
at least meet Queen b3 with Queen b6
okay
I've played a computer in this variation
before and I know that if I play Bishop
f5 it's most likely going to harass my
bishop or even after Bishop f5 there's
Queen b3 Queen b6 and then Knight h9h
for I could play h6 but you know
preparing to meet Knight h4 with Bishop
back that's not correct Queen c2 I think
is a fine reply stopping the development
so I think still that said I'm going to
deploy my Bishop to f5 right now and
I'll be content with giving up this guy
for the night okay well so much for this
idea of Queen b3 Knight h4 idea so if I
want to hang on to my light square
bishop I can do that so far I'm pretty
happy with how things have been going
it's slow a slow approach in this early
stage
nothing too tactical is going to occur
pretty static structure so
ponds the D ponds fixed symmetrical
structure so I'm just thinking about h6
yeah I'm gonna go with h6 just to not
allow this imbalance of night for Bishop
exchange I think it's still going to
play here yeah I've had it and do this
before in faster time controls so it's
still playing similar in this lower time
format I cannot win a piece with the
Bishop takes Knight rook takes and then
g5 because there's Bishop takes Knight
so let's preserve this Bishop and this
is just a little bit misplaced okay so
this was my idea behind c6 and I think
this is a situation where we both would
do well to maintain the tension having
the a file open up is pretty good
so probably 97 I mean where else is he
going to go
97 I'm not doing this to defend my queen
I'm doing this to watch over E 5 and I
don't know that there's really much
difference at this point between 6 and 9
f6 I don't know let's just let's just
develop tonight probably just won't
matter at this point so okay he's 6
and it doesn't really matter what the
time control is against computer it's
going to make a move every second or two
so all right let's get this in so far
it's pretty much a symmetrical position
aside from our queen bishops
placement yeah in fact I'm a move up now
because of this knight h4 Knight f3 move
so it's as if I'm it's as if I played
this with the white pieces
so just castle I'll probably can't do
without that
so yeah pretty much everything
symmetrical if he was right here it
would be completely the same so okay I'm
a move-up how can I try to put that to
use huh what would I like to have happen
here this is my bad bishop
that's always an idea to try and get
this exchange in light square bishop
exchange this might be an ID as well a
5a for putting a question to the Queen
a5 Queen takes Knight takes hmm I don't
know it like for a moment I was thinking
rook c8 but I'm not quite sure what
that's even doing you know rook c8 with
this an idea of c5 but if I'm breaking
like this at the d4 square I'd really
like to have my knight here instead so I
don't know that moving this rook and
this is the only wreck I'm considering
moving I want to keep him here in the
event of Queen takes pawn takes so yeah
oh well here's the other remove night
here 94 maybe that's maybe that's an
idea
for some trades yeah let's go for that
95 all right
maintaining the structure recapture with
the piece maybe they do similar no okay
so I'm gonna back up at this time not
all the way to h7 I want to keep this
Square open as a flight square you kind
of step on one another's toes could be a
problem with the bishop on each seven so
now I guess it's being prepped here this
advanced c4 hmm okay
do I need to play c5 myself hmm I feel
like I've been here before in a blitz
game against the computer uh-huh c5
Queen takes Knight takes actually my
Knights aren't protected so I wonder if
on c5 there's moves like Bishop here I'm
probably not a knight would go here
maybe I could actually transfer my other
night here to the e4 square Knight f6 e4
I think it's a good strategy to get the
Knights I have to abort against the
computer hmm so I mean I'm kind of
factoring that stuff in playing against
a computer here I'm seeing you know I
get the Knights off
tricky pieces tough to calculate and
that's where there's certainly an edge
the computer has an edge with the
calculation so Knight f6 into e4 suppose
Knight f6 c4 now I let's say I just
ignore it and play Knight here I think I
think I like that idea let's let's just
follow in my king Knights footsteps okay
I kind of expected that and I guess just
94 let's follow through if it's a bad
idea it's a bad idea but at least let's
be a little bit consistent once again
maintain the structure and will they
play c5
no okay
I'm not sure what to do here
uh-huh I'd like to see it close-up maybe
on the queenside and I don't want to
capture still hmm I'm considering queen
bee four and then a five hmm not sure
what that's really doing hmm
I'm struggling to find a a good move
here I'm not sure what can it moves
I have giving up the central point pawn
takes and then Bishop here and that's
our sure that I want to do that Queen B
4 a 5 a 4 hmm on Queen before if c5 I'll
exchange then and then play a 6 and then
be quick to defend my B punch sure
there'll be pressure with rook d8 d7 let
me try yeah let's try for this okay so
the Queen's are off oh you know what
they're going to go for minority attack
mm-hmm Bishop takes there's f3 e4 and I
have some concern about my bishop taking
with the C pawn there's quick access to
the seventh rank therefore this must be
best a 3 and B 4 is going to happen and
I better stay out of the way of b4 with
tempo I do maintain pressure on this
square okay so they're going with this
approach huh rook to d8 and then here
yeah typical computer ness rook b3 just
putting pressure on it like that my rook
is accessible on d7 of Bishop g4 that's
actually quit a bit annoying
I can play f5 but then when the bishop
drops back f6 and my bishops trapped so
how to defend this pressure against b7
it's tricky huh bishop d8 rook b3 Bishop
b6 there's a 5 Wow
tough spot this idea of the pressure and
the pressure against this pond and I
don't want to move this pawn either it
gives off a 6 and these bishops will
absolutely kill me hmm this is very
difficult it's a tough game tough game
we have here huh
I wonder if I'm having to do something
dramatic like Bishop here pawn takes and
then have the b8 square to watch over
here hmm yeah I don't like this I I
don't want to move this pawn i I think
it's just not helpful yeah here rook b3
rook d7 Bishop g4 I have to play f5 the
bishop goes back and what am i doing
about f3 with my bishop being trapped I
think I have to go for this and I think
it will take because it's seeing this as
a positive and it is but I think I had
to make that decision let's start with
this rook here and then prepare to
defend b7 laterally alright maybe you
sneak my king over just for a moment
okay
so yeah me grabbing some space are you
okay let's go back
g4 could hit with tempo I don't want to
play h5 put-upon fixed on a light square
probably not a good choice and maybe I
have to maybe I should try to get in my
pond at f5 although King g3 to f4 this
is very strong position for the King
it's double isolated ponds this is gonna
be a nice home for a king huh
should I be approaching with my king
towards here on g4 I probably want to
maintain my bishop on this dog and not
maybe maybe I should be approaching with
my king play rook b8 on rook b8 on rook
b3 let's go here I think I'd be a bit
happy to see this advance mm I think
it's sometimes miss play it seeing it as
a positive okay I don't know that that's
correct they're happy to see that
advance okay I think King D 684 there's
rook c5 let's let's improve first Keaton
the King belongs here okay yeah let's oh
you know it's gonna happen sacrifices oh
boy
an e6 Bishop takes pawn pawn takes rook
takes c6 and yokes
everything is hit well on f5 there's
Bishop d3 ouch if I'm not
five I needed to fill my bishop yikes
okay hmm yeah an 86 Bishop takes pawn
it's gonna happen okay so what do you do
I don't know let's try this put my pawn
in a pin here comes the King oh man now
can i play a six I better start moving
hmm let's do this I guess yeah
that's such a strong King position
uh-huh
I mean this move could be played I can't
take let's let's try a six now I have
some defense for and yeah there's also
that move okay ah take I guess man
Bishop d3 and then pawn push with the
discovery Wow where did I go wrong in
this game we're gonna find out okay
let's still try to put up some
resistance look here
pressure on this guy at some point Oh
all right that's hitting right away huh
they're gonna come over but happy to see
that move really it's a bit weird all
the rooks are coming off Oh
at the end you have this advance don't
you yeah that's what you have up your
sleeve
and the King is just entering hmm King
takes rook e5 I got to take and when I
do
kingi v f6 g7 and that's it if I take
with the pawn I'm dropping this guy
also my bishop has no squares by the way
I'm playing without a bishop it's
another way to view this yeah this is
dead he five is hitting or that mouth
huh okay let's get my king back over and
yeah I still can't move yeah I'm gonna
run out of moves my bishop has no moves
let's put this guy up on a dark square
huh
let's take I want to keep this square
controlled and now I have to make a
concession with my king and then II five
is still hitting I got no moves with my
bishop or pawns it's up to my king and I
have to go in reverse and it's never a
good sign okay yeah this one's this
one's done why aren't they hitting with
e5 oh okay well they have the time to do
that
King d4 and I'm yet again having to move
my king I guess here maybe this is
they're doing this they're gonna play it
on 50 moves and then finally make
progress I know their tricks
alright I have a king position watch out
less than 10 seconds yeah they're just
toying with me twenty with me yeah I got
nothing let's go back here g5 come on
just hit it with e5 alright let's come
over here are they just won that time
yeah this one's completely busted
yeah time forget about it it doesn't
matter I'm in a tough spot I don't know
why if I wasn't played sooner I think
the computer
stock fish will be pointing out a 5 much
sooner let me go back
I was just wondering I didn't make a
move at the end my mind was on what
exactly I was I was wondering is there a
way that white could still make progress
without even playing this advance yeah
just to force my King back and have the
King enter and hunt down my beef Han
yeah
the point I'll be curious about again
I'll be checking this out with the
buttstock fish very soon but when we got
to this point right here hmm I mean is
it already this difficult well this was
probably a bad idea so there must be
something better than Queen to b4 we'll
see what that move is what would be
better than Queen before but when it did
get to this point after the capture and
now that now this might an idea of a
minority attack is a problem hmm maybe
maybe rook to ca is better we'll have a
look but rook to ca anticipating this
capture and then being in a position to
recapture with my C pawn taking with the
e pawn this idea of a later Bishop g4
being disruptive to my rook that was
quite annoying computer makes it look so
simple
hmm yeah I'm definitely in rough shape
here after rook c3 what was a computer
suggest at this point I to do this and
it's just a completely complete disaster
on the kingside huh okay well yeah it
was a long road ahead a very slow grind
I think they could a computer could have
been quicker in the end with the e5
advance but the probably the the
advantage never slipped 4y fantastic
post for the king
my bishop is on this nice diagonal but
every square is controlled he's in a way
just not even existing he's just uh I
don't know staring off into space here
it's not inconveniencing the white side
at all okay let's dive right in let's
see what we could take away from this
with the aid of stock fish okay
let's see what we could learn from this
one as expected a pretty even position
to be expected when we have a completely
symmetrical position after about a dozen
moves really I don't even consider g5 at
this moment that's what stock fish wants
to do g5 Queen takes pawn there's 97 I'm
getting the piece mm-hmm so on g5 have
to do this and then I recapture and then
Knight here with Knight f6 I should have
at least considered this I threw it out
the windows I had in my mind out Queen
b3 I just played Queen b6 and I was
forgetting that this was an ID it's not
winning a piece but it is winning the
bishop for a knight exchange okay
g5 takes takes Knight f3 d6 let's just
carry it out a few more I'd have six
pretty natural h3 g4 I'd be thinking at
this point about Bishop d6 could even do
something like this playing with the
bishop pair now which is nice
okay I've had this position before and
bullets against computer I will keep
this in mind
okay Queen b6 let's fast-forward a
little bit here pretty even
pretty normal if moves even position for
sure and now wants to play rook after c8
instead of Knight to e4 I played a 94
here and this was right around the
moment I said I think I was expressing
that I didn't see a purposeful move for
my rooks but I guess this is purposeful
I've played 94 it'll still hold it
around the same evaluation but it's
important to try and figure out the idea
behind it I'm assuming it's prepping
this advance like follow suit and then
c5 okay I guess this is the direction I
need to go what can we say about the
difference between these two rook F to
ca and Knight to e4 Knight to e4
it's just welcoming more exchanges
trying to simplify the position mmm okay
playing against the computer maybe not a
bad idea to have those nights off I was
saying that but hmm maybe my focus
should be you know from an objective
standpoint just from trying to find the
best moves I need to do what I need to
finally get my rooks working so a pawn
break needs to happen a half-open file
needs to come about and it's even going
towards c5 immediately so yeah I guess
this huh
rook have to c8 and then here I mean
that's that's what a light ended up
doing and I am a one move up so I can
maybe try and get this file open right
away this is what it has a follow up
takes takes and now c5
I don't know that I would have liked
this this is there's a difference here
with yeah there's a difference here if
white is to capture like this with the
pond still on c6 I like having this
particular structure b6 c6 and b7
it doesn't weaken the be 5 square but
you know going for this variation where
after rook here
chop-chop c5 now I've given up to be 5
square so after Queen takes pawn takes
yes I have to play for my rook that's
true but I really don't like giving up
this square it's now a permanent
weakness and you know there's I don't
know it's maybe a long way off but my
fear is that some piece getting to b5 is
just super annoying I'd much rather have
this pawn back just a step and then I'd
be fine with the double peep with the
doubled be pawns but not with my pawn on
c5 okay so here 95 takes takes e5 I
don't know that I would play C 5 here ok
another suggestion now is Knight d7 with
a temple against the bishop and then c5
ok so this is different at least because
on Queen takes Queen are they taking
with the knight yep you can keep the
structure as is maintain the structure
ok well that gives me a little bit of an
idea as to how to make some progress
here in this completely symmetrical
position that we had aside from the
queen bishops all right so I was in
search of some exchanges both nights
coming out I'd have 6 they still wanting
to do what ok it's shooting for a 5 here
I think I was pointing out this idea of
a 5 a 4 don't know in this very position
but I went in this direction instead
both nights off bishop there and now it
wants to take Queen takes Queen I saw
yeah I played Queen before and it
doesn't like that it's not a huge shift
but it is a shift I mean up until this
point it's pretty much locked at zero
Queen before and now I'm in rough shape
Queen takes bishop takes a three first
capturing he takes bishop back and now
we'll come up with rooks III that's what
the computer played its pointing out
Bishop g4 right away on rooks III what
would I do
hey v oh why didn't I consider a5 o you
goof a five and our rook be three
there's rook a seven oh my goodness why
was I so blind to that maneuver I've
done this before not in a video I'm not
referencing some video where I've done
this before but just having the pawn on
a5 and defending laterally like this I
was so locked into rook here to here so
in it seems awkward
he has no squares he's tied down but at
the same time the rook on b3 is not so
great and it's a piece that could be
dislodged as well with a four oh that
was so silly I had plenty of time to
around around this point to formulate a
plan it's where I put in my biggest
think after Brooks III simply a5
okay c1 I mean here's the other thing I
mean this is useful if I just saw this
idea of defending the b-pawn by way of a
7 this is useful in not allowing the
minority attack to come about so easily
huh
that's a that's a bit upsetting oh are
they calling for b4 right here no I read
it wrong h4 h4
weird what's what's the story with this
rook b3 okay seven Bishop d6 and then
here wow that's a pretty deep move
diverting the bishop off of this
diagonal just to crash through and get
the super valuable heart of my structure
Wow Rigby 3r okay seven I have to give
up something here or hit them with an
in-betweener
Wow they want to go for this Wow how
about that that's pretty cool that's why
I like um you know checking out games
with computer it just shows you these
different really opens your eyes to
these different possibilities Wow and
he's without any squares Bishop takes
rook King takes could get this rook back
or just play in a way where you keep the
rook right here and don't take it like
c1r okay six suppose this move trying to
release the rook along the B file now
there's Bishop e7 no now it wants to
sack that's going to get crazy wait a
second I'm supposed to take back out
Bishop takes here wow what a what a
variation this is chop chop and then
rook to a1 a takes rook takes B - yeah
sure even yeah okay anyhow I was
completely blind to a5 or okay seven the
rook a five and rook a seven idea and
after this it's just death how else to
say it's a it's a crushed structure and
very slow and steady progress nice to
see how
the king was slowly improved upon how my
bishop was killed
yeah I wasn't really much I could do I
had no constructive plan at this point
and it was just a very very slow grind
and it's fast-forwarding a little bit oh
let me let me see if I was correct with
his sacrifice on b4 a6 yeah and I know
the computer we're going for that and
not a fun not a fun position at all I
have an extra bishop right not really
he's still not playing ouch
yeah so crawl up into a ball and yeah
this is just good
I had a glimmer of hope I just didn't
see the idea after the rooks were off
but yeah this guy is dropping Bishop c4
+4 as you're seeing bishop here King
here or even throwing in a check first
pick your favorite way to win at that
point is white huh
and this is nice bishops under control
completely
and eventually I have to give ground
with my king was it calling out for a 5
right here as soon as I went back with
my king he 5 ePHI would be fine as well
not wouldn't know I guess the downside
oh yeah why was I thinking if I was good
Oh at that earlier point instead of
Bishop c4 I thought you 5 was better but
this helps out my bishop that's one one
downside and of course there's a
tremendous evaluation shift after you 5
he's at least free to do something he
has a square or two to go to but what
about a 5 right here instead of Bishop
c4 is e5 good yeah that's another
approach so I take take and he's just a
beeline right towards the edge fun
yeah so this was done for quite some
time I didn't see the idiot
the a5r okay so have an idea I needed to
see that yeah and it's just completely
busted here time was irrelevant
I want to I want to just go back very
quickly to this moment here with okay I
didn't see a five rook a seven but was I
right about this if I played rook here
rook b3 and it's it's it's calling out
for b6 I do not want to play b6 I don't
know how I would eventually defend my c6
pawn and b6 look at how easy this is
just target practice for white B 6 and
then C 5 mmm
okay I guess that's how I would have to
approach it but this early isn't fun not
at all Bishop takes Bishop a6 playing
against an isolated pawn in such a
simplified position this guy here is a
liability
I have no attack there's no dynamic play
against the White King yeah I won't want
to play with that structure and if I was
to do this yeah sure enough Bishop g4
and I'm already having to be accurate
it's a pawn disadvantage Bishop c2 rook
c3 and then f5 yeah ok if I played f5
right away it's probably a flat-out loss
bishop d1 yeah I have to get rid of a
pawn here just to open up this square
anything else
f3 is trapping here yeah that's downhill
as well so yeah I needed I needed to see
this idea of a 500k 7 for whatever the
reason it was really it didn't come to
mind there anyhow feel free it's been a
while since I played against the
computer I've only done it
maybe a few times now with the standard
play but anyhow it's a it's interesting
to see how the computer could absolutely
smash you and that's exactly what happen
one wrong slip and it's just a very very
slow grind but as usual hopefully there
was a thing or two that you're still
able to take away from this little
beating and feel free to leave any
comments in the comment section below
and I'll catch you in the next video
that's all for now
take care
you